Hey ladies and gentlemen here we are
back again with Hilda is at Tuesday it's
Tuesday thought we'd do a livestream
today just because like I said we did a
live stream in the regular episode so
that normally go up on Tuesday but you
know how that's going
we probably are gonna end up I mean from
this point forward are you just gonna
want to do every single episode as a
live stream like the main episodes I'm
looking at the link to this and it
doesn't say it's live oh well it's a no
down there no alright yeah it's like
nice I just realized we were recording
we were recording a show earlier today
and I was watching it back and I was
like the same shirt on so we had the
same shirt on we did yeah look yeah it's
like you don't I mean I got up early I
left the room but I didn't know what you
were wearing today alright so what we're
gonna do today maybe give a little uh
because we did an hour yesterday but I
guess we'll just do a brief little thing
of new Netflix horror series jus on
origins because somebody asked us about
that I think yesterday or the day before
and I said I would look into if I had
time to stream it like - to binge watch
the whole thing that I would end up
reviewing it today and I did because it
wasn't as long as I thought it was yeah
so I actually just sat down and watched
her last night at 6 episode Z 28 minutes
long so it's a little less than three
hours time investment now Tom's gonna
say right off the bat you know I'm gonna
say it was just let's just get that out
of the way okay it's good quality you
know the way it's shot and I guess the
acting is good best Japanese horror I'm
not big into it you would definitely
have to be into and I'm not saying that
you necessarily have to be into The
Grudge franchise although it does help I
think what they did with this one you
know what the funny thing is okay so
I've seen the original Jew on the
Japanese one which is very good I've
seen the remake the American remake
which I think came out in 2004 I want to
say her 2006 was
michelle gellar that was also pretty
decent and then I had forgotten but just
last year I think like that we went to
the theater and saw the reboot Grudge
wouldn't have I mean I remember it not
being terrible but the fact that I even
forgot that I had seen it is nothing
like that a really good sum about some
by Japanese [ __ ] it's it's it's based
in ambience a lot of it and I just think
it lacks texture every [ __ ] frame
looks the same just telling mine this
one is very much in line with the with
the growth ology now the thing about it
is that there have been I believe four
American movies made of The Grudge but
in Asia there's it's a whole [ __ ]
franchise I think there was like 12 or
13 movies there was a video game
there was even like a grudge ring
crossover like with the two villains
like the two girl villains and they're
like fighting each other which I haven't
seen what this one did this one it
seemed like it I guess because the
American remake that they did recently
like last year you know didn't do so
well and got really like critically
panned was that they wanted to take it
in a different direction like so what
they did with this one which I thought
was actually a pretty good idea was they
took the mythology of the idea of the
movies being like you know a curse that
comes from a quote-unquote grudge like
something terrible happened in the house
and then everybody who comes in contact
with the house is like now cursed going
forward and like you can never get away
from it and stuff so they took that but
from what I could understand in the
universe of the series The Grudge movies
exist but they are a fictionalization
of stuff love the real stuff that
happened in the series you know I'm
saying so they're almost kind of like
going back a level and get like going
meta and saying you know yeah the movies
exist they were made in this universe
but they were you know just based off of
the real [ __ ] that we're gonna tell you
about right now which I thought was kind
of like an interesting take on it so
this is not I saw like a lot of reviews
saying that this was like a pre
wall and you would think that because it
was called Juwan origins it's not
exactly a prequel in the sense that it
doesn't you know lead up to the events
that happened in the first grudge movie
now I think the first grudge moot I
think it was a short film and I think
that came out in 1998 and then the main
film came out in 2002 I want to say so
this does happen before that like in the
grudge's timeline but it doesn't
directly lead up to it now I don't know
if there's gonna be a second season of
this it wouldn't surprise me if there
was because they did leave a lot of
stuff hanging and you know they left a
lot of questions unanswered and so you
could tell that they were kind of
wanting to go farther with it um so
we'll see if they do or not now one
thing I will say I don't think you I
don't know I'm just gonna say I don't
think that you would have needed to see
The Grudge movies to watch this but it
does help because at least you know you
know what the whole premise of it is but
since it's not directly tied into it I
don't think it's as important but one
thing I will say and that a lot of Asian
horror has this a lot of Japanese horror
has this where and I think we've talked
about this before maybe we talked about
it when we were reviewing the Ring
and the American remake of it was that
Japanese horror movies tend to be more
episodic or more cyclical you know
whereas Western story tellings tends to
be much more like you know like rising
action falling action like you know
looks more like a parabola where I feel
like Asian storytelling is more circular
or more episodic now that's kind of what
you're getting with this and I will say
that even though the episodes are short
like I said there's only six episodes
and there are only about 27 28 minutes
long each when it first starts out
they're kind of coming at you from like
four different timelines or like four
different characters and you're not
entirely sure at first like how they're
gonna relate to one another
like you know that it's all gonna relate
to this house and this curse and
whatever it was that happened but there
you know it takes a while for it to kind
of get in the
like you figure out like how all these
characters like relate to one another
you know I'm saying so I will say that
you kind of have if you really want to
watch it if you're really into this kind
of thing that you kind of have to be
patient because even I at first was just
kind of like well you know you know what
does this have to do with that thing
because it seemed like a couple of
things and it seemed kind of scattered
at first and like I wasn't really sure
like how it was all gonna get tied
together but then as it went on the
thing about this one too is that this is
one where you definitely definitely are
gonna have to like if you're gonna watch
it you definitely are gonna have to pay
attention because like I said there's at
least four timelines going on it goes
back and forth in time it starts in 1988
and then like it jumps ahead to 1994 and
then jumps out in 1997 and there's also
like flashbacks and a lot of the
characters and the houses and if like
that are related to one another in
certain ways and so you really have to
like keep track which it was kind of
hard for me to do so this is one if you
liked it the first time you probably are
gonna have to watch it again like to
catch all of the [ __ ] that happened and
if it's hard for her to do them it's
impossible for me to do yeah he likes
very linear instance I mean so this one
I mean it stayed mostly like within each
episode it usually stayed within the
same year but it went back and forth
between different character situations
and [ __ ] that was like happening like
simultaneously and then like in the next
episode it would skip ahead but then
sometimes it would go back to like it
would do flashbacks you know what I mean
one thing that I did like that they did
with this they did this a little bit in
that kind of crappy or forgettable movie
that they made last year - was that all
about okay I forgot a theater yeah we
did it was cuz yeah we were seeing all
the horror movies it's like I like I
said I remember it not being terrible
but the fact that I kiddin that I didn't
even remember any good it just like
didn't and what language it's in doesn't
matter because we saw a parasite there's
a Korean flick I remember that movie
well well everybody remembers that
because that movie was [ __ ] on yes
but yeah so it's it's kind of a thing
where um like I said I don't know if
this is gonna have a second season I
feel like it kind of needs one now what
this did interestingly like I said they
seemed like they were trying to reboot
not reboot necessarily but they were
kind of trying to go like a little bit
off the beaten track from what like the
movies were because the movies were
based based very much on you know the
ghost woman and the little boy that you
know with the cat and the noise and all
that kind of stuff and jump scares and
that kind of stuff so it seemed like on
this one they were kind of trying to
ground it a little bit more there's no
jump scares the ghosts are not super
scary but they focus a lot more on like
the psychological stuff and like the
actual crimes and the actual abuse and
stuff like that that caused the grudge
in the first place so I will say that
yeah we do I might very well I'm not
sure I mean I don't really went anywhere
other than Publix and I had pollen it
might be yeah because the pollens really
bad this year but so it's kind of a case
where it's you know whereas the movies
focus more on like spooky you know jump
scare type of stuff this one focuses a
lot more on kind of like the human
stories and I will say that I was
actually because it starts out pretty
slow and it starts out like with pretty
more psychological kind of stuff there's
like one guy he's like a paranormal
investigator and it kind of starts out
with him and then there's an actress and
she's like been hearing like creepy kid
footprint footsteps in her house and she
goes to him for help and finds out that
the boyfriend has been in the cursed
house and she doesn't know where it is
so they're trying to find out where this
house is because nobody knows and then
there's all these other like
interlocking stories look at this
student and stuff but you quickly get
into a thing where I think it was only
like the second episode where there
starts to be like some really like
shocking scenes of violence they're
spaced out but you know there'll be a
thing where it's like everybody's just
kind of like talking or like talking
about the haunted house or whatever and
then all of a sudden you have like a
dude with a kid in a car like
beating the [ __ ] out of a kid or you
know the the one student to you me I
think her name is who gets like dragged
to the cursed house two of her
schoolmates
like hold her down and like this guy
rapes her and like so it and then as it
goes on it gets like more and more like
graphic so I'm gonna say that if you're
real squeamish you can probably like
stomach the first couple episodes but
there's moments in the later ones where
I mean spoiler alert
there's [ __ ] like a woman getting a baby
like a fetus cut out of her pregnant
belly and like a phone stuffed in there
um you know there so there's [ __ ] like
that there's a lot there's a lot of
rapes there's a lot of like domestic
abuse like dudes beating the [ __ ] out of
women dudes beating the [ __ ] out of kids
it's Japanese stuff Japanese [ __ ] does
that guys yeah stuff like that so so I
guess I wasn't really because I had seen
The Grudge and I'd seen stuff like that
it's you know the movie the mythology
the movie does have that in its heart
because that's kind of what caused the
you know the original grudge and the
movie was you know this this abuse of
this woman and this child so that has
always been in the background in the
mythology but I would I guess I wasn't
expecting like I wasn't offended by it
or anything but I wasn't expecting them
to like show it to the extent that they
showed it
that's probably strong points of the
movie though yeah well yeah I definitely
think so too and I think it was good
that they spaced it out and did less of
like a ghostie jump scary thing and more
like a human horror drama type of
problem whether it was though is the
writing the writing style like he says
jumping everywhere jumping around
everywhere slow starts it's just not
something for a person like me this
short attention span I got it you know I
mean I got I got I got I got a low
tolerance for that kind of stuff I gotta
ask Jenny you know when they do a
flashback to Jenny is this a flashback
she'll tell you yeah if the story isn't
linear
I'm [ __ ] lost I'm like why are they
jumping back I get pissed well something
I mean there's a lot of reasons that
they do it it's like I know in some
movies they do it just for the sake of
it yeah but in a lot of movies they do
it for a specific purpose
yeah in this one I thought they did not
really use to they did kind of an
interesting thing in this one and I
of hope if it has a second season I kind
of hope that they do a little bit more
than this but I liked the idea they
didn't really go super into it but the
fact that this cursed house was almost
serving is like the fulcrum of this
almost like a time loop because stuff
was like repeating itself because there
was like some really cool [ __ ] with like
there was this really one of the
creepiest images in it which was like
this weird shadow woman that had actual
eyes and it was like really kind of
creepy and somebody saw it like outside
of the window like in 1952 and then as
the story goes on you see that that was
an actual person later who was trying to
get into the house like in 1988 or 1994
or whatever it was like him one of the
other timelines so the fact that they
like overlapped all the timelines um you
know kind of like I said this this house
was almost kind of like the center of
this you know spreading disease I guess
or like this is this kind of curse that
was like had all of these spokes coming
out of it and that it was like happening
at all times like in all timelines I
thought that was a really neat idea and
so I kind of hope that they do a little
bit more with that because if that
seemed a little bit underdeveloped but I
don't know if they're gonna get more
into that like as you know as the series
goes on or if it goes on like in a
second one because like I said they left
a lot of [ __ ] hangin like I don't really
want to spoil all the [ __ ] but you know
the the paranormal investigator
character who's not in every single
episode but he's kind of the guy you
start with and he's kind of like the
through line like through the whole
story um there's some [ __ ] with him and
the house and like why he escapes the
curse and you know is there a reason for
I mean there's got to be a reason for it
because they bring it up more than once
but they don't really tell you what that
is so so I feel like they'll probably
like finish that up now like I said if
you're not into Asian horror and are not
used to this type of storytelling which
like I said a lot of Japanese movies
actually do have this kind of structure
then I would probably advise against
watching it but if you're really into
Japanese horror you are kind of like
ready for something that kind of like
jumps all over the place and that maybe
like I said it seemed a little
scattershot
you know cuz some of the characters
there was like a serial killer type
character who was only in like one or
two episodes like in a couple of scenes
and I've thought that he was going to be
more significant so I don't know if that
dude's gonna be like a bigger character
moving forward or you know if they just
put it in there and they forgot about
him I'm not really sure like what what
that was doing I did like also that they
did kind of like almost like a macrocosm
type of thing because every year that
they went to like in 1988 they were
talking about Chernobyl from a couple
years before you know there was like uh
all these bad earthquakes that have
happened in Tokyo like in you know
whatever particular year like 1994 so
it's kind of like they were kind of
saying like how this this smaller like
domestic type of horror like that
happened in this particular house and
caused this curse was also like mirrored
like in the larger world which I thought
was kind of like a neat thing but like I
said I feel like it needed a little bit
more like those ideas I think needed a
little bit more fleshing out which may
happen later on I mean it's hard to say
because it's a series and because this
is only the first season of it so I'm
not sure if they're gonna continue these
particular threads or or what or if it
was just kind of like they weren't even
really thinking about it but yeah if you
if you don't like like if you're if
you're into [ __ ] that goes back and
forth and time and that you really
really have to pay attention this is
definitely not one that you can just
watch casually like and just be doing
other [ __ ] and not really paying
attention because if you're not paying
attention to like every single thing
then none of it is gonna make a goddamn
bit of sense because like I said it's
the same character through many years
and then there's [ __ ] going back with
this dude is that this house and like
this timeline and that timeline so it's
like if you're if you're not prepared to
to do that I can see how it would kind
of get on your nerves yeah but um I
thought you know I didn't love it um but
I thought it was pretty decent and it
was a lot better than that then that
movie that we saw yet I totally forgot
as far as series the fourth new series
those wasn't as good as say like blood
machines well now yeah I like blood
machines better although like I said I
think that's really it's really
interesting how they're doing different
stuff like they're kind of stretching
the definition of series I guess yeah
because that one was another one that
was just kind of like it was literally
episodes but they were really short
right um so it worked though yeah it did
cuz it work they because I think those
was a only three series oh there was
reeds there were only about 15 minutes
each I think weren't they
yeah because I think the whole thing
ended up being only like an hour long or
something I think there were 20 minutes
like Egypt there's almost kinda like
music videos in a way weird yeah it's a
bunch of really interesting ideas I
wanted more of that I'm kind of hoping
they make some more of that yeah yeah I
mean and this one was kind of the same
because it's like this one you know yes
it's a series in the sense that at six
episodes but the episodes are so short
that really this could just be like a
long movie a three-hour movie um and
like I said I feel like there and
despite that even though it seems like a
three-hour movie it seemed like there
was a lot more development they could do
maybe it was just because they had so
many characters and so many timelines
that they didn't really have a lot of
time to focus on any one in particular
and they were just kind of focused more
on the relationships how they overlapped
with each other and how this house like
impacted like all of these different
live like I said like the spokes of a
wheel is kind of but um I do kind of
wish they had done a little bit more
with the characters they should maybe
like you know pared down the cast a
little bit like I said the serial killer
character unless he's gonna come into
play later on I just I didn't get
because you know he was like in the
first episode and then like I thought
that that was gonna be like I'm like
kind of a massive like plot thread like
going forward and then it almost seemed
like they kind of forgot about it
um so I don't really know if that was on
purpose or if they had some like grand
plan or something like that
alright mangoes yeah the blood machine's
is on shudder and shudder
yeah you should be on there for free
yeah you want to see that one yeah
that's like I said you don't even need
to like it's it's cool to like you know
watch like for the story and stuff but
it's like you don't even need like the
dialogue or anything you just sit there
and look at it it's very much it's
amazing like if you were a kid and you
have a red heavy metal magazine yeah
there's a bunch of little cartoons and
stuff an animated sci-fi slash horror
called heavy metal it's like something
out of heavy metal yeah good
it's it just drops you right into this
totally different universe with a bunch
of weird [ __ ] happen very unique science
fiction type ideas really stylish really
really visually style yeah it's like I
could I'm it was felt like it was like a
visual orgasm yeah and it's low budget
low budget acting but it [ __ ] works
it's like imagine like a super high
caliber star crash movie but the
writing's good it did kind of give me a
little bit that's all yeah and it's uh
and it's like it's being a b-movie like
a super high quality b-movie on purpose
like that's the tone they wanted yeah
and it was just such a good man and it
kind of brought me back to seeing Star
Wars the first Star Wars like a new hope
for the first time when I was a kid it
brought me back to that it was like I
was seeing a new type of science fiction
yeah yeah whole new genre of it you're
like wow it's kind of taking you back to
like Flash Gordon [ __ ] Buck Rogers
[ __ ] foot honors a moderate a super
modern take on it yeah little kind of
throwback yeah visually stunning it was
gorgeous colors are all wrong um [ __ ]
the way the movies edited the acting's
kind of [ __ ] stilted it's the
storyline is [ __ ] weird
you got ray guns but they don't act like
ray guns you've ever seen before in a
movie you just got to see it it's
[ __ ] totally unique I mean cuz like
they think but the thing about it you
know like what you were saying with
acting was because the whole project was
so stylized that it almost seemed like
well that was a deliberate choice yes
everything else was stylized - yeah the
actors have accents that don't really
fit the character the [ __ ] acting is
kind of strange it's just and the edits
weird it's just it's a work of art yeah
you can but it worked it worked the
whole thing works a hundred percent
because it just kind of came to lot oh
thank you very much it looks super super
expensive but it's weird how that's kind
of [ __ ] juxta supposed I can't fun it
you know suppose just suppose he's not
even drunk it's like where it's cut off
kind of offset by this strange acting
and this kind of storyline that a real
expensive movie would never have a
storyline like that yeah it's just
[ __ ] really really cool really cool
like some okay here's a good example it
kind of reminded me of a super high
quality Riddick movie kinda but weirder
much weirder than Riddick yeah I found
Riddick kind of gave me some good vibes
sometimes you know where it really kind
of did its own thing you know um but
it's kind of like that but visually
you'll see you'll see it's just [ __ ]
weird man really weird yeah mango badger
was coming and that's and I guess he's
talkin about juin origins where some
about that rape scene in the storyline
that went with it was odd I thought that
was a little bit odd to you like one
thing the rape seemed like kind of light
I was like oh we're going here okay
that's a kind of upsetting but so that
went that way but then I didn't really
get and you know spoiler alert spoiler
yeah I'm washing or anything I didn't
really get that after that happened to
her and she was clearly very traumatized
and everything but then she like goes
and like willingly like have sex with
the rapist or like is once you know what
the rate is it's I'm just like did the
house possess her I kind of feel like
that's probably what had happened
because then at that point like he she
goes and makes him do that thing with
her mom and all that other stuff so yeah
so I so I didn't really I guess this is
another one where I'd have to like watch
it again because maybe I missed it but
I'm not really sure like what effect
that and because it seemed to have like
a little bit a different effect on
different people like you know in the
you know that went in the house because
it did affect everyone that wins the
house just it seemed to do it in
different ways almost like in a
possession type of way but it manifested
itself differently like in every single
person like some people would just like
see the ghosts and like freak out and
dive of like you know heart attack or
whatever then some people seem like they
got possessed and then got murderous you
know in the would go and murder people
and stuff so you know items like I said
I haven't seen other than the first
grudge movie and the American remake
that's like the old pretty much the only
one I've seen you
the one that came out last year that was
like the only one so I know like the
rough mythology but I didn't really know
like what all the rules of it were I
guess necessarily but um I wanted to
talk a little bit too about Netflix and
horror series because really I mean
correct me if I'm wrong but they seems
like they haven't had a really really
good horror series since haunting of
Hill House which was 2018 Kingdom was
good although I don't know if I'd call
that necessarily a horror series I guess
it is in the sense that it was zombies
but it was kind of more a historical
drama yeah that happened to have zombies
in it yeah and it was Korean so it
wasn't an American series right so that
was we're actually more made for that
market this market hasn't had one really
good one since Walking Dead and Walking
Dead it really hasn't been good in all
my well I'm talking about Netflix horror
series yeah well that's on Netflix but
that's not a Netflix series
yeah well haunting of Hill House was
amazing and so I'm kind of like I'm
really excited because Mike Flanagan who
did haunting a philan house he's doing
haunting a Bligh Manor which is coming
out next which was like season 2 but not
really because it's gonna be based on
turn of the screw which like I said it's
got to be like a million times better
than the turning which we saw last
January which was also kind of awful um
which was kind of a shame because it
seemed like it was good until the end
yeah
like if they hadn't ended it like that
it would have been a perfectly passable
movie but the ending of it was just like
you know up here let us kick in the nuts
by yeah those some of those movies who
were seen at AMC were quite
disappointing really the best [ __ ]
horror movie that we've seen recently
with that horror sci-fi movie the varium
I liked that movie I loved that that was
a really I loved [ __ ] mind [ __ ]
movies that was the predator 1 of alien
[ __ ] parasite movies yeah no no no
but in a totally different oh they're
well aware sight doesn't kill you the
same way as hunter does yeah but that's
how I imagined that movie it was a
[ __ ] good movie and it was still a
lot of mystery to that movie
remember the weird writing that's what I
liked I really liked
I love unsettling [ __ ] yeah like I love
Gore to you like I you know I'm into
gore and everything as much as the next
person I love like horror comedies and
stuff but if you can if you can make a
movie that's just like really weird and
just really unsettling it just has like
these really really creepy like imagery
if so you know and it's it's hard to
pull off but if you gonna do is end I
thought it was kind of a joke at first
and then it goes on good no man it's
just [ __ ] horrible it has the same
guy in it that was from artists
self-defense he's in yeah what's that
guy's name oh [ __ ] I remember his name I
do but it just went right out of my head
and he's he came out with two movies yes
I think so he came out with two movies
in a row that [ __ ] blew me away
artists self-defense and vivarium you
guys guys said this is in that movie
about Facebook - the social network I
didn't see it play and Mark Zuckerberg
if you guys haven't seen those he knows
- but Bavaria missed a horror movie yeah
if you like weird flicks that look like
a really good one and [ __ ] artists
self-defense as a [ __ ] bad-ass boobie
about [ __ ] coke and evil conch food
dojo yeah very much kind of like
something out of [ __ ] count Dante
yeah I was certain he said mango badger
says yeah the invisible man that had
Elisabeth Moss in it that was a good
that was a great moment yeah it was okay
and underwater was good too yeah peep
for some reason people were [ __ ] all
over underwater and I liked underwater I
did too I liked it a lot it was survival
horror some people didn't like the story
because will not much happen they just
did you know so what it had good special
effects it was kind of like alien one
but underwater yeah big surprise
I mean alien one was slow so I did a
standard a standard alright
that's I don't know I feel like there's
there's kind of a faction of horror fans
that not named any names or anything but
it's like some of them it's like it
seems like there has to be something
happening like every [ __ ] second and
the story has to be calm real real
complicated and convoluted it was a
simple [ __ ] story
you're very classic sci-fi or like alien
one it's alien one is the same story
almost that's what yeah pretty much
I think that was really the kind of
the main criticism that I saw up
underwater was that oh it's basically
just like an alien ripoff which I don't
know if it was so much a ripoff it was
just an omage and that you know it's
when you do just like a survival story
like that it's like you know whether
you're ripping something off it's like
there's only so much you can do with a
story like that and the movie looked
great it did I thought it looked really
cool we saw it on the big screen yeah we
saw it a couple of times on its bomb and
hard but you can you can get that off
the Xbox one for like four dollars yeah
and I recommend that one get that one
Annie HD yeah I like that one good yeah
yeah so it's you know I'm and there's a
fine line between cuz I mean I'ma be
everybody knows that's watches the show
I'm a big fan of like you know Artie who
are elevated horror I like all that a24
stuff and I know some people don't like
that it's not everybody's cup of tea not
all of them are great but I like to get
immersed in a horror film I want to like
you know feel what this person is
feeling I want to feel like what would I
feel like in that situation and I feel
like if you're just going at this
breakneck speed you know just trying to
get to the next thing or trying to get
to the next Gore gag or whatever that's
you can't really get invested in the
characters you can't really get you know
you're not upset when they die you don't
do this on the other and like I said I
really like you know slasher movies and
things like that that are fun where you
just like watching it for the body count
you just want to see how Jason's gonna
hack up the teenagers or whatever that's
fun too but it's like if I'm going to
really be scared by a movie or disturbed
by a movie to be disturbed by a movie
you have to care about the people that
are in it and you have to care what
happens to them because if you're just
like watching it and you don't give a
[ __ ] about these people then it's not
gonna scare you because you're not gonna
relate to them you're not gonna like you
know sympathize with their situation so
I do feel like some of that you know you
do have to have some kind of build up
and shit's not scary unless they show
[ __ ] don't be a normal first I mean
every Blake every horror writer knows
that you have to like horror comes from
like deviation from normality deviation
from good so you have to like establish
that before you can deviate from it and
that's where the horror comes from so
you know I don't know somebody asked in
the cookbook we should make our jaws in
last meal or death
Romeo and then make and eat it that's
actually a herd ability good I don't
know if I could pick like if I knew if I
was on death row for whatever reason and
which I hope never happens but uh but
yeah and they said well this is the last
thing you're ever gonna eat before we
fry you um [ __ ] lobster probably a can
lobster bacon baked potato with sour
cream chives with my you know what
though you know what would happen and
I've I don't know why I've randomly
thought of this before
but I was thinking to myself because I
think when I was like reading about some
criminal and they were talking about the
like the last [ __ ] they eat I was like
you know what would happen I would
request like all this stuff that I
couldn't afford to eat or you know
everything it was like oh I have to
worry about getting fat I can have like
cheesecake and all this other [ __ ] and
then like when it came time and they
brought all of it it's like I would have
a stomachache from nervousness from
being executed and I wouldn't be able to
eat it John is talking about it the
first it was good there's some about the
second part wasn't quite as good as the
first one yeah the second one I liked it
but the first one was just so much more
effective maybe I guess because the
characters were kids so it was I mean
the kids were a lot more I guess you
felt like a lot more sympathy toward
them and it seemed scarier because they
were more scared I also like to dr.
sleep and that movie bombed yeah some
people didn't like it I liked it I liked
it too yeah I mean like I said it wasn't
my favorite that I saw that year but it
was actually like way like much much
much better than I was acting and
actually I'll tell you this right now
and I don't hardly ever say this I liked
it a lot better than the book I did not
mean I didn't really like the book I
have to say I haven't I don't know I
can't really remember the last Stephen
King book that I read that I really
really really liked yeah hey man go
badger yeah it's three you got a C man
go go on there and go watch blood
machines go see the varium that's on
there to that I think it to get that off
the Xbox yeah we raised that on the Xbox
and then you can rent it on YouTube too
yeah and then see artists self-defense
you like all those yeah that was no not
hormone video yo and that's like I don't
understand it yeah it's pretty good but
I mean and as far as like other movies
we've seen lately that aren't horror
movies I think mope was probably
yeah mopus pretty good I love that movie
cuz that was like I said that was just
like it was not just like Boogie Nights
but it was similar to Boogie Nights but
yeah so um you wanna you want to wrap it
up yeah we wrap it up alright yeah cause
like I said yes sander said I love David
Lynch he lets characters sweep the floor
for literally five minutes I can deal
with slow yeah exactly it's like you
know it depends on how you do it and I'm
not saying that there aren't movies that
are like super slow pretentious just for
the sake of it because there are but a
lot of times you know like what we were
saying before movies that are not told
in a linear way you know sometimes
people are doing that because they think
they're being clever or whatever but
most of the time when filmmakers do that
they have a reason for doing that you
know what I mean like because they're
making a particular cover they're trying
to like make parallels between
particular things going on or whatever
and speaking of nonlinear timelines I'm
gonna try and finish up all three
seasons of dark this week so because I
want to do a review on all of it this
weekend sometime like Saturday or Sunday
I'll probably do a live stream of that
now we're probably doing a live stream
tomorrow but it might be a sidetracks
unless I can find another new movie to
watch tonight we'll see how that goes
but yeah so oh the vast of night I still
have to see that like I've had that
recommended to me a couple of times so
um I'll get around to watch and actually
maybe oh thank you
team-killer Cody I actually yeah I think
I've had that recommended to me a couple
of times and I wrote it down
so maybe if I can find that to rent
tonight maybe I'll watch that tonight
and I can review it tomorrow we'll see
how that goes i think that's sci-fi
right yeah all right so we're gonna wrap
it up for today we'll be back again
tomorrow either doing a side tracks or a
movie review thanks everybody for
stopping by so you will talk to you
again